basf is the world's largest chemicals
company
last year it posted record profits of
4.8 billion euros
much to the stockholders joy
at the head office in ludwigshafen the
company proudly announced that dividends
to shareholders would rise as they have
for the past 10 years
since 2004 dividends have risen from 85
cents to 2 euro 70 in 2013.
we pay very attractive returns
over a 10-year period it's always been
more than 3 percent
so we think that we represent a very
attractive investment
possibility attractive investment
analysts estimate that basf shares could
pay dividends of more than four percent
in the coming year
shareholders and insurance companies
like munich re and allianz can expect
dividends of some five percent
that's certainly a better return than on
a savings account
so far taking a risk on the stock market
has paid off for investors
and shareholders are profiting from the
european central bank's low interest
rates
makes more sense for companies to pay
dividends than keep them
if they don't have to pay interest or
penalty
interest on the other hand companies
also have more problems financing
themselves now
we've had restrictions on awarding loans
from regulatory agencies so it's very
important that money flows to investors
and dividends keep rising
last year the tax traded companies paid
out a joint total of more than 28
billion euros
that could increase this year
and that's good news for shareholders
but money that's paid out in dividends
is not invested
and as fund manager carsten hillck
observes the investment mood in germany
is gradually becoming a problem
taxes are increasing other charges are
rising regulation is increasing and that
leads to regulatory costs
the shift to renewable energy is also
increasing costs
taken together that's a combination that
leads corporate executives to reconsider
investing in germany
so despite rising stock market prices
german companies wonder how long the
positive mood will last
today's high dividends are the result of
yesterday's high profits
but what about the future
in ludwig's huffin baesf's spokeswoman
emphasizes how much the company is
investing
is
we're focusing strongly on future growth
so we're investing heavily
by 2018 we will have invested 20 billion
euros globally for new facilities
however companies usually invest in
those places where they sell their
products such as the united states and
asia
only a small fraction of those
investments are made in germany